Star Wars Jedi Survivor expands on its
predecessor's Fallen order in numerous
ways whether it be the size of its
worlds to explore the amount of tools
kalkasters can take on the Empire with
or the different Cosmetics he can sport
while doing so looking good Cal Jedi
Survivor has a lot going on here are the
five things I wish I knew before I
started my playthrough
if you take even a single step with Cal
in the game I implore you to dig deep
into Jedi survivor's settings the game
has a ton of options to customize the
game to your play style which helps
offset some of the game's quirks when it
comes to how Cal controls while some
things you will likely Tinker with over
the course of your time with the game
there are a few things I recommend doing
off the bat the first is setting the
field of view to its widest setting on
Console the game doesn't have an fov
slider there are the five options for
fov ranging from narrowest to widest
considering that the game frequently
throws several enemies at you at once
both ranged and melee having that
increased field of view makes them all a
lot easier to manage also consider
turning the camera's sensitivity down a
bit I set mine to four much like Fallen
order Cal and his camera can feel a
little loose to control a look
sensitivity of 4 felt like the best of
all the options to me one of Fallen
order's sticking points was its map
which many felt was confusing to
navigate while I don't think Survivor
completely resolves those map issues it
does allow you change colors designating
its disparate elements Tinker around
with the various colors till you get it
looking the way that feels the most
distinct to you if you pre-ordered the
game picked up its deluxe edition or
both you'll have some Cosmetics to play
around with from the jump while you
can't alter Cal's lightsaber until you
find your first workbench you can
immediately change his outfit the rebel
hero clothing items belong to Luke
Skywalker at the end of a new hope the
hermit is based off of Obi-Wan Kenobi's
look from his Disney Plus show and to
the scoundrel options are Han solos each
jacket shirt and pair of pants from each
set can be mixed and matched and each
even has several color options to make
them more unique when you're playing the
game there's going to be a lot of codex
entries that you accumulate sometimes
several at once making it difficult to
understand exactly what knowledge you've
gained thankfully the game's data bank
has a recent Tab and allows you to view
every informational entry regardless of
where it fits in the data Bank in the
order that you discovered them Jedi full
and Order borrowed several elements from
from software's popular series of action
RPG games and Survivor only doubles down
on that comparison by making its primary
Planet Kobo feel at times like the lands
between an Elden ring when you arrive on
the planet and get past its initial area
to reach the settlement of rambler's
reach you'll see a gargantuan sprawling
open world with enemies Milling about
and locations in the distance to explore
this is because rather than having you
explore a new planet for nearly every
Mission Jedi Survivor has you often
returning to Kobo and venturing into a
new area within it while at first the
urge to explore the planets every nook
and cranny is strong in the same way it
is when in Elden Rings the lands between
unlike that game many spaces in Kobo are
blocked until you progress far enough in
the story to unlock a specific mechanic
that will let you explore further in
some cases you'll even unlock the
necessary tools to access a previously
inaccessible area only to be blocked
once again further down the path
fortunately the game provides numerous
shortcuts to unlock and thankfully now
allows you to fast travel between its
meditation points so if you do find
yourself wandering off the beaten path
it's fairly easy to return to where you
need to go quickly but if spending time
exploring a new area only to discover
that part of it is segmented off until
you learn a new technique sounds
frustrating I suggest focusing on the
game's story which will inevitably bring
you back to many of kobo's most
interesting spots now equipped with the
necessary abilities one of the other key
souls-like elements of the game is a
returning feature from fall and Order
when Cal dies the XP he accumulated up
to that point is attached to an enemy
which Cal must return to and strike if
he wishes to regain it I recommend when
spending XP initially to focus on Cal's
Force meter at the start of the game I
felt as if it was being rather stingy
with how much I had at my disposal
before depleting the meter only to try a
third Force push and finding myself now
unable to do it no matter how you spend
your XP don't feel compelled to spend an
experience point the moment you get it
very quickly there will be upgrades
available to you that require two or
more points in order to unlock many of
them will serve you better than some of
the one point ones ever will
Jedi Survivor introduces two new
lightsaber styles to the mix Blaster and
cross guard both are incredibly useful
and once I had them both unlocked I
rarely if ever swap them out for the
single-sided double-sided or dual
wheeled options you will acquire Blaster
before you get cross guard but if you
want to get the cross guard as soon as
possible you need to make a choice at a
point in the story two objectives become
available to you one will return you to
Kobo and the other will bring you to its
shattered Moon the shattered moon is
where you will uncover the cross guard
so traveling there first will allow you
to get your hands on the kylo ren-esque
lightsaber faster the cross guard has
Cal holding the double-sided lightsaber
configuration but with a single blade
that is much longer than his standard
single-sided option attacks in this
stance hit a lot harder and have a much
bigger reach than other melee options so
it's definitely something you'll want in
Your Arsenal sooner rather than later
because of Jedi survivor's much bigger
scope there are a lot more mechanics at
Cal's disposal many of which are
introduced so quickly to you before
moving on to the next thing that I found
myself often forgetting certain moves
available to me the one that's easiest
to forget but is also one of the most
useful is confusion when an enemy is
highlighted on a controller by holding
R1 or right bumper and pressing the
circle or B button Cal can cause that
enemy to attack their teammates for a
brief time this move can be upgraded to
allow you to both confuse multiple
enemies at once and for longer periods
of time when you get stuck into a fight
you can often find yourself too busy
blocking parrying dodging and attacking
your enemies to do some Mind Tricks on
them but you should take every
opportunity to use that ability when you
can as it makes fights way more
manageable there were even points where
I was facing off against two giant
beasts at once only to use confusion to
have them both finish each other off
without me having to lift a finger when
fighting with a companion instead of
pressing the circle or B buttons when
hold R1 or right bumper pressing square
or X instead will have Cal call on their
friends to Target the highlighted enemy
while companions are constantly engaging
with the bad guys in a fight you'll want
to spam this ability as well as it will
trigger the companion to do a stunning
move opening up the target for a big
strike from you even if you're facing
just a single opponent your companion
won't do that critical stunning attack
unless you trigger it so always remember
it's available to you when partnered up
here's a quick rundown of other elements
that are easy to forget stopping at a
meditation point doesn't automatically
reset your health and refill your stim
packs as in the first game you have to
choose to rest in order to do so Necco
that you can eventually ride unlock a
bigger double jump so when you're on
Kobo and find a ledge that's just Out Of
Reach call on an echo to help you out if
you find a building or large object
tucked away in a corner of an area more
often than not there's a collectible
hidden behind it Cal will die if he
falls from too great a height and while
double jumping or later on when you
unlock it four stashing can sometimes
cancel it out some drops will trigger an
automatic death regardless of if the
area below is accessible to you or not
Cal's slo-mo ability which allows him to
slow down enemies and Blaster bolts
within a certain radius only lasts a
certain amount of time however if Cal
Attacks An Enemy they will automatically
be knocked out of slow motion while
their cohorts remain slowed you can
upgrade this feature down the line to
not only last longer but allow for an
additional amount of attacks before
reverting an enemy back to full speed
but when using the slo-mo have the
strategy for What audio you're going to
tackle the enemies affected by it in
order to utilize it to its full
potential
there are a bunch of different vendors
in Star Wars Jedi Survivor that all sell
different things and require different
currencies if you want new hairstyles
outfits or music for The Cantina in
Ramblers reach you'll need to speak with
Dola whom deals exclusively in priorite
shards Z the Droid who you meet early in
the game only takes data discs which can
be traded for new perks or parts and
colors for bd1 cage takes Bounty pucks
which you can give in return for Blaster
components and modifications to your
blasters charged shot and on Jetta and
anchorite will provide you with new
lightsaber parts and materials in return
for Jetta Scrolls if you want to focus
on specific items that you want to
purchase the relevant Collectibles are
located in relevant locations for
example for those looking to unlock all
the available parts of their lightsaber
they'll want to collect Jetta Scrolls
which are the primary collectible found
on Jetta those looking to change Beauty
one's look will need data discs which
are found predominantly in high Republic
ruins you'll also uncover different
seeds to plant in the cantina's garden
and fish to add to its fish tank but
know that neither of these Collectibles
can be traded in for rewards and make
sure when you find the characters on
Kobo that unlock the Holo tactics table
on the cantina's second floor to check
it out it's a fun little mini game that
offers zero cost to play but can net you
some nice rewards in fact I recommend
doing the rounds at the Cantina between
every story mission to not only offer
you a reprieve but to hear new rumors
that will make exploring the massive
world of Kobo a little more manageable
Jedi Survivor has a lot to offer Star
Wars fans both from a gameplay and lore
perspective the knowledge I've run
through in this video when known at the
start of the game will hopefully make
your playthrough go down smoother than
blue milk